he's saying the father knows when the
hour is he's saying I do not know when
the hour is so he is ignorant he's
saying I do not know one second was he
crucified on the cross yes is that
weakness or power power us to us is
power God dying on the cross is
power for
our did you guys know the definition of
emergency is a serious situation that
requires immediate action imagine your
loved ones under Rubble in earthquake or
bombs being dropped in Gaza or in Yemen
or in Afghanistan where there's an
earthquake brother and sister we're
working with one um to get immediate
relief to those who are in need please
go to the link and donate whatever you
can inah and let this be a that use for
your use there for your brothers and
sisters when they needed do you know
what we believe about Jesus you do know
we believe he's the Messiah we believe
he's a prophet we believe he had a
miraculous birth we believe in his
mother Mary um we have a whole chapter
on Mary in the Quran the whole chapter
is called Mary
and it talks about the the birth that
they had which was you know Jesus Etc so
we believe the only difference is the
following we don't believe Jesus Is God
we don't believe believe he claimed to
be God we believe God is the father who
sent Jesus that's why if you look into
the Book of John 17:3 it talks about the
one true God the one who sent Jesus so
Jesus talks about his God so I'm sure do
you believe Jesus Is God yes okay but
you do know that nowhere in the Bible he
claims to be divine there's nowhere in
the Bible he said I am God
you guys know that
he yes but the thing is for example if
you lookis it also speaks about how the
word of God is yeah like he is his word
and the word okay word meaning what the
word is God okay okay so we say in the
beginning was the word yeah the word was
with God and the Word was God okay good
so the thing is this if in the beginning
the word was uh with God there's God and
the word was with God how many
word okay but then then okay but the
thing is if the word if the God is the
word if the God if the word is God and
is with God how many gods two cuz
there's a father and there's a God so we
say no way Jesus said like for example
when it says if you've seen me you've
seen the father as I I am in the father
if you listen if you look into those
other verses he clearly say the same
thing with his companions there is no
way explicitly he says that like for
example when prophets came down with a
message if you disobey the prophet you
disobeyed God so it doesn't mean the
prophet is God as well but there is if
you look into the Bible nowhere and
Jesus himself when he went to the
mountain of Gethsemane he prostrated and
he prayed he's always referred in John
17:3 clearly says the one true God whom
sent Jesus but also first Timothy it
says he was fully man but he was also F
God where in
first in the Bible and if if the if the
Bible is the word of God and if if it is
no the Bible is you have evidence for
that because the Bible has been changed
[Music]
but translation is separate I accept the
transl we have the translation of the
Quran but the Bible has been changed you
can the Christians accept that yeah but
if it's been changed how could it be the
word of God the thing is the Bible
hasn't changed there's different
versions of the Bible people there's
some people that still origal B there is
no original Bible there is if you read
you have C sinus yeah the earliest one
you have that goes 100 years later there
is not there if you look into the Bible
if you go to John 753 to Mark 811 it has
a little footnote it tells you you know
the story of the adultera when Jesus
says he with the first he with no sin
cast the first stone yeah do you know
this is a fabricated story if you go to
your Bible they have a little foot now
and tell you this does not belong
because I studed before I came to before
I chose any religion I looked into the
Bible I looked into Islam Christianity
Judaism Hinduism I was so searching and
I read the Bible one of the reasons I
didn't accept the Bible was for two
reasons number one scripture not being
preserved the Quran has been memorized
by millions it's the way it is but it
doesn't mean it's from God but at least
it's preserved number two it has
prophecies if he say it's preserved but
doesn't mean it's from God that kind of
destroys the main purp following so for
example following yeah for example the
reason the reason I don't sorry finish
I'm saying the whole point is if you're
saying oh just cuz it's preserved you
believe it more not necessarily because
it's from God that kind of defeat the
point of why we follow God so we are
Christians because we follow not about
but we know that this is the word of and
cuz even in the Quran like you guys say
that you guys should people should also
read the Bible they should read the the
The Testament that was given to Jesus
not not not not what you have today what
I'm saying is the following I say the
Quran is preserved I'm saying that this
doesn't necessarily be the reason why
it's from God preservation means that
what was sent down is exactly what we
have today that shows number one that it
has not been changed by mankind number
two what makes it Divine is what is
inside it the Quran has prophecies
specific prophecies in the Bible it says
you shall know them by their fruit and
by their prophecies the prophet Muhammad
upon him made specific prophecies all of
them have come true it cannot be a
coincidence number one number two it
affirms what the old scriptures were
sent he affirms Jesus he affirms Mary he
affirms Moses he affirms The Testament
that was given to Jesus so when you read
your Bible it says Jesus went to Galilee
and preached the gospel what gospel Mark
Matthew Luke and John they came hundreds
of years later which gospel was it
preached the gopel the gospel of good so
the good news we call it whates you know
uh we call it the inj in the Quran it
tells us that Jesus was given the injil
we believe he Pro he preached that
gospel that he had Mark Matthew Luke and
John are individuals that never met
Jesus never spoke to Jesus never walked
with Jesus who are claiming things that
they don't know about Jesus imagine I
talk about you 400 years after you died
I don't know nothing about you I never
lived at the time you get they they that
time Mark Matthew I promise you I'm not
Che Matthew was one of
the Jesus Noth Mark Matthew luk and
johnp that worship Jesus he I remember
before he was he was a what tax
collector and then he yes yes yes he was
was a tax collector yes he Jesus so he
was
he Mark Matthew Luke and John go to
Christians forget me fact check when you
read the new jum's commentary of the
Bible he talks about John yeah we he
says we don't know who John is we don't
know if it's John the son of Ze John the
presb John the Apostle these individuals
that have been given these names we do
not know not I'm not talking about me
you get me Christian authorship does not
know who they are names were given to
these people these people never met
Jesus never this is what's the funny bit
they talk about him being crucified how
could you be an eyewitness when you
never there's not a timeline between
these individuals and Jesus so what we
say is that's the reason why you have
the Old Testament you have the New
Testament you have the final Testament
why cuz the Quran had to come down let
me ask you a simple question if God
Almighty sends a scripture and that
scripture gets
corrupted what do you think God will do
in his wisdom to correct
that what do you think you would do okay
so I canot what would you do as a as man
we should never try to understand what
God will possibly do because God works
in different ways if we look at uh the
Old Testament and you like oh God saw
sin and then God decided to flood the
whole earth and kill everyone would I
think that's what God would do if as a
human possibly not if I was back at that
time and someone ask the wise what would
God do now that he sees that everyone's
sinning do you think I would never guess
that oh God was going to flood the whole
earth and but he send them signs yeah
what I'm saying yeah he sent no no but
doesn't mean that will be my first guess
that's what I'm saying I for the
question that you just asked I cannot
give an appropriate answer because I'm
not God nor do I know God's intention
and nor can I ever judge or create any
judgment that God create so I canot
answer that question true but let me
tell you how I will answer it if I know
that if I was to put myself in the
position from a God's
if he sent scripture and those
scriptures got corrupted the very simple
logical thing I'll do is send send yes
corrupted I would send another Prophet
with another message and preserve that
and correct the mistake information
that's
op as that's what God has done exctly
sent the prophets no that's what I'm
saying he sent the prophets and Propet
it has been written down in his word
okay but what we're saying is the word
that you have he's saying that after
Jesus CHR that the word is corrupted so
what would God
do SC techically to us is actually the
final the Quran the Quran and the
prophet Muhammad that's my argument is
he would send another Prophet that will
look Jesus said I've got many things to
say unto you but you cannot bear them
now for he when the spirit of truth
shall come he shall guide you onto all
truth he shall not speak of himself as
he hears he should speak and he should
glorify me one second put Islam to a
side show me one religion that glorifies
Jesus believes a messiah believes in
mother believe in his miracles believe
he's going to come back and kill the
Antichrist except from Islam show me one
religion that glorifies Jesus the way we
do the way the prophet Muhammad when he
heard the message what does he say as he
hears he shall speak he shall glorify me
so Jesus is saying I've got many things
to say unto you but you cannot bear them
now for he he says he when the spirit of
truth shall come shall come so the
question is the following when the
prophet Muhammad came he did not preach
anything different he said to us God is
one when you look at Jesus everywhere
Jesus when his companion came to him and
said oh good Master what must I do to
get eternal life he said why do you call
me good there is only one good and that
is God every single time God's giving
credit to the father if somebody's given
credit if you come and say to me Ali
that picture is beautiful man I go to be
honest I didn't draw it man you want to
meet my teacher you are thanking me and
I'm telling you who the source of that
is so when we are thanking Jesus or even
Muhammad I don't care who is for that
matter or Moses who deserves true credit
you guys how old are you don't mind me I
lady's age but we're in our 20s you're
in 20s yeah imagine you give birth you
have kids when are you gonna have kids
yeah hopefully imagine your children
grow up and they say you know what Mom
you've done nothing for me I'm going to
go and thank
David is David when we associate
Partners to God and what's the second or
third
commandment Thou shalt not worship any
other gods so we're seeing as Muslims
the only thing we're seeing is this you
Christians are close to us we can marry
from you guys we can eat from your food
you guys are very close you've lived
with us in centuries Muslims Jews and
Christians have lived together the only
thing that the Quran tells is the
following tell the people of the book
let's come to Common terms between us
and you that we worship God Alone the
only thing we're seeing is let's worship
the one that Jesus worshiped which is
God that's the only thing we're asking
other than that the major difference are
not there we've got a lot of things in
common but the only thing is this let's
give credit to the one that's created us
your heart is beating do you ask your
heart to beat do you ask who longs to
breath when you're sleeping no you don't
for example your eyesight who gave you
this Jesus
God did God give you this did God make
you a heart or did Jesus to us
one one to say you know like I give you
an example you can give me no example
about Trinity water ice and steam Ste
yes so they're all in this they're all
different form but are the same and I
think the things with not that I
understand the whole like you know
brother and sister in Fai and like how
that went but I think the major
difference in what we believe as
Christians
is that
we God will you you can never try fully
understand
God he's
God I'm saying so who are you to not
believe that God can truly bring himself
as man as he knows that he's the true
the only covenent the only one because
they had been in the past Old Testament
in the Old Testament you don't believe
that what you mean you said God can be a
man no God can come as a man in himself
as a man one second all right do you
believe that do you genuinely believe
that God can come as a man like me like
flesh bones okay all right
that's okay just hear me out hit me out
hit me out and tell me if I'm wrong no
EOS we're here for the truth yeah let's
put ego I'm not here to win an argument
look I'm not here to I'm here for the
truth okay can God
lie why not why not cuz you said God can
do anything good now what you done is
you use your rational and logical I
didn't you don't need Christianity Islam
or Judaism for that if we put all
religions aside and say let's talk about
God and if I said you know what guys God
can lie what would you say to me no cuz
God is all perfect so you are rejecting
an you're refusing to reject an
attribute of lying because of how
perfect he
is okay one second that's why he was the
we
he these are things you're cing from the
Bible
obviously we're Christians so this is we
know the same way like with the Logics
behind what you pre it's also based in
the which is understandable no no my my
logic and rational I'm putting the Quran
to aside let's put the Quran to as side
let's put the Bible to as side we're
talking about god let's just let's just
talk about God cuz you know why this
will make sense can God lie you said no
yeah good cuz it goes against his
attribute he's the he speaks the truth
okay can God
die no because it goes against attribute
true so now you said he cannot lie
because he goes against who he is you
said he cannot die cuz it goes against
who he is when you say he became a man
you're saying he became ignorant he
became weak but that's your attrib one
second he
came L Jesus he Jesus never lied he he
was never
ignorant he was yeah he was everything
we were not might
say is angry I accept that shows anger
so therefore the only thing that you can
say to me that Jesus has done which you
might be like his man is to show anger
not even that I have no problem with his
anger you know when he flipped the
tables I have no problem with that you
said that when they came and said to him
when is the hour what did he say it said
no one knows the hour oh you said he was
not ignorant but apart from who the
father okay okay one
second if some If he if some if he's God
and they're coming and saying to him
when is the hour he's saying I I do not
know the hour not the angels in heaven
except the father one second please hear
me out he's saying the father knows when
the hour is he's saying I do not know
when the father I do not know when the
hour is so he is ignorant he's saying I
do not know one second was he crucified
on the cross yes is that weakness or
power power us to us is power God dying
on the cross is power res for our sin
noer sacrifice
L you're reading the
Bible let's talk about power the he from
the dead sister you are where did you
get this information from the the the
the Bible okay I said to you putting the
Bible in Islam to a side you're
preaching trying explain okay no problem
but if I speak to the Quran Allah says
in the Quran did they did not crucify
him nor did they kill him I'm not coming
from the Quran because it's your
religion against M I'm saying different
belief I'm talking about who God is you
said he's not ignorant he did not know
that I was sister hit me out pleas me
out look let's not get into preaching
mod because preaching preaching I know I
know I hear you I know you're passion I
love I love the I love the energy but
I'm
saying you said he was never ignorant he
did not know the hour he you said I said
to you can he lie you said no can he die
you said no and I said to you why and
accept I'm with you he cannot lie die
I'm with you 100% we're on the same team
when he became a man he was ignorant and
he was weak okay wait wait for our
explanation let me finish my sentence
let meish let meish my sentence how does
God you said he cannot lie he cannot die
how do you make him ignorant and weak
okay he goes against
attribute but no preaching I want I want
I want this is now the Bible aside right
and now we're just focusing on God so
let's just primarily focus on God right
and the idea of why do you always think
that as a man we can truly understand
the movement of God why are you trying
to incorporate our knowledge and our
understanding into the god who's created
us it's the same way like in a way where
you can say oh people that think the
logic they don't believe in God are like
oh what but God lets War occur God lets
this occur how can God who is all good
all loving let War occur yes
cuz what do we do we focus and
understand also the most wise TR
understand
never so then why did you then why did
you guys say if that's the case that we
cannot comprehend God then why did you
say God cannot lie maybe he can lie why
are you judging God God no no no what
good so look look how is that hit me up
look look you said perfect thank you
look you said you said God cannot lie
when I say God cannot be a man you say
no Ali he can be a man oh when he cannot
lie you say no Ali cannot lie why is it
when you say he cannot lie I accept it
when I say he cannot be a man you say no
no he can be a man it's not it doesn't
follow look he cannot lie and die but he
can be a man it goes against his
attribute no but the thing when he was a
man when we as a Christian we believe
that if good you're going to scripture
I'm saying see you had to go to
scripture about scures now
can't you was just log you all of you
were logical when you said God cannot
lie that's logical rational it's not
it's of course are you telling me look
okay I don't I don't follow the I don't
follow the Bible I don't follow the
Bible and I know God cannot lie go to a
Jew he would say God cannot lie it's a
logical thing sister you don't need
Scripture for it even if I get ath
scriptures that you said go to a Jew
sces go to aww does believe go to a man
who's atheist what would they say he say
I don't believe in God say I don't
believe in God and then they also say do
not you know the same way we like do you
believe God is good of course he has to
do you believe God cane no he cannot I'm
with you on that my point is I'm on you
I'm with you look I'm saying God cannot
lie and die we're in the same team look
I'm look look I'm on your team we're on
the same team the moment you say God is
a man you have a problem because you're
saying God can became he became weak he
became ignorant that goes against
attribute that's your understanding
that's your understanding of what a man
okay why you saying cannot lie why is
any can lie then understand of what a
man is okay one question is lying an
attribute it's an attribute lie look lie
weak weakness and ignorance these are
all belongs to him you
accept I'm done I'm done look look lying
ignorance and weakness is part of an
attribute you say no to one and you
accept two how does that make sense
please explain you say lying he cannot
do weakness he can be weak and he can be
ignorant I fully understand that but how
sister that's where I'm coming from I
get what you mean and and and and just
never wait this is I'll go back to this
one question and Jesus has a do you
believe God is good yes why do you
believe God is good because he has to
imately cause his attribute of who he is
no but where do you gain that from I let
me tell you where I get that from I get
that from the Quran and also also even
if I didn't have the Quran I will say if
God exists he has to be all good because
it will go against attrib but there's
people can be evil no but there's people
who believe it who say God
exist is not all good but that's why
because something bad happened to them
yeah but not it was not based on that's
thing when you say when I asked you yeah
God is you said if God is good you said
yes and you're like oh why do you
believe God is good you said because of
the Quran the same way when we say oh we
believe God is good because of the Bible
I accept that I accept that I accept God
being good believe God is good if God
now comes down as man he cannot that's
attribute that's the thing would he Li
sister it goes against let me hear me
out look am I a man am I a man yes okay
am I composing bones yes do I have a
heart if I cross the road and get hit by
a car do I die okay are you telling me
that a God Almighty who created you know
how big the universe is yeah very mive
humongous so the one that created that
became a little speck like me came to
Earth and died on the cross
yes okay so he loved him so much that he
sent his son by the way his son
son remember okay so I go to I go to I
go to the judge and say listen yeah
commits all the crimes here's my son
that's Justice that's the biggest
oppression ever and what does it say for
for for sin be death you need blood
sacrifice yeah that's to me with all due
respect that's that's I want to be
careful I don't be be rude look blood
sacrifice in Islam there is no sacrifice
you sin you repent there is no but
doesn't mean it's good cuz what does in
the Book of James say
Works Faith was not works is dead you
have to do works so this thing of Jesus
came and died for your sins you get that
from where the Bible yes if the Bible is
not the word of God all of the stories
fall apart the Bible is not preserved
check it yourself Bart Man Bruce Metar
these are Scholars yes one is obviously
he was a Christian he's not Christian
anymore John 753 to Mark 81 there are
books added in which how many books do
you have do you follow the King James
version 66 books 66 books yeah there's
83 There's 7 2 how could God sister we
have one Quran 114 chapters not a single
word has been changed it's preserved now
I'm not saying that's the reason it's
from God that's prophecies it's and the
message it comes to is the same message
Jesus preached Adam Moses Noah all of
the prophets said what God is one not a
single God is one denominations we have
different sex all of them let tell the
difference all of the sex that you
believe we believe we have they all
believe God is one they all believe the
Quran is from God and they all believe
the prophet mamm is final messenger
Jehovah's Witnesses uh Mormons Catholics
you go to the Catholics some of them
even worship to turn to Mary Mor don't
have the Bible not Mor no Mor I don't AC
I don't I never said Mor je Witnesses
they're actually not classified as
Christians they are they Heretics
Heretics Mormons are not Mormons are not
morm Mor are out Mor and Jehovah Witness
are both not why because Jehovah
Witnesses say what they they
if I'm not mistaken they accept the
father is the one true God John 17:3 it
clearly says the
one they don't have I don't think their
Bible okay good but they have
Bible I don't
think we can never live up to
stand he for us he came down and US
exactly was Muhammad a prophet he was a
prophet of God so the way we believe we
enter Paradise is by Grace meaning the
following I could pray I can fast I can
do all this stuff it's ultimately by the
grace and mercy of God we enter Paradise
that's yes good but the thing is this
you believe that there was a sacrifice
Jesus was the blood sacrifice the human
sacrifice that was done good so you
believe that also we believe that is the
greatest Injustice to get and because
Allah says in the Quran no soul should
bear the burden of another Soul why
should for example when you have birth
when you're going to give birth you bear
the sin of what
done in your scripture you B you know
the pain you're going to go through
birth it is because of Eve tempting Adam
we don't believe that we don't believe
why you why you why are you suffering a
consequence to somebody else in Islam
it's very simple I sinned I Repent to
God there is no Muhammad Moses Jesus I
don't need to go for anybody I have a
direct relationship with God and as
Muslims we invite our Christian sisters
and brothers to worship God Alone the
one that Jesus worshiped all we're
saying is Jesus worshiped God worshiped
the same God it's like me if I give you
£50 and you start thanking the £50 £50
thank you I gave you it why you thanking
the 50 Jesus was sent by the father
worship the one true God by woring God
we worship Jesus you that's idol worship
and it's against it's yeah this is that
was also thing like Tech from our
perspective yeah from our
belief yeah yeah and and and and and the
funny thing is the Old Testament is the
Old Testament is from the Jews the Jews
say exactly what we're saying they say
God is not a man how could it be that
you're following a scripture a Bible
that you hold in your hand that belongs
to them and they are saying God is not a
man but the Jews do believe that God
God no they don't
speak I promise you they they can't even
mention his name cuz that's how
glorified they have him they don't
believe they St the reason why they
believe you guys are Idol worshippers
and by the way they insult Jesus they
believe Jesus is going to be burning in
Hellfire and his mom is in adulter we
the reason why remember when Jesus said
I've got many things to say to you and
they will glorify me we came because the
Quran came because the Jews were
disgracing Jesus by saying he's going to
burn in the Hellfire and his mom's and
AD the Quran came to preserve her honor
and said she's the most holiest woman to
walk this Earth and as Muslims we have
to honor and believe in Jesus because of
the insults that the Jews were doing
towards Jesus do you get it so to us
sisters again look thank you for
listening I love the energy by the way
the energy that's why I believe you know
a lot of Christians when they come to
Islam they are like on fire because they
genuinely the Zeal is there I know the
faith and thing I really admire that
like with you guys I can see that there
but the only thing we're seeing is this
God is one and one thing I'll leave you
on in the Bible I can't remember where
it is it says many on that day will come
to me and say Lord Lord did we not
prophesize in thy name and in thy name
cast out demons do you know what Jesus
going to say who cast out demons in the
name of Jesus who prophesies in his name
Muslims or
Christians Christians do you know what
Jesus going to say get away from me I
never knew you he's going to tell these
people I don't know you you know why
because on that day Jesus going to say I
never told you to worship me that's why
we believe Jesus hasn't died in his
second coming is going to come and tell
the Christians I never said worship me
Allah says that in the Quran when Allah
asks him in the Quran on day of judgment
did you ask them to worship you and your
mother besides me he says oh God you
know what's in my heart I don't know
what's in your I've never said to them
such a thing so my dear sisters when
Christianity came to uh Africa that's
like one uh president he said he said
when the missionaries came to Africa
they taught us how to pray with our eyes
closed when we opened our eyes we had
the Bible in our hands and they had our
LS Jesus is not a white man this whole
kind of notion yeah exactly he's not
this things that they have yet he's not
a black man he's none of this stuff okay
God is one worship him alone and you
know very well how many times have you
guys prayed to the Holy
Spirit
the one second One Second One Second One
Second One Second One Second sister you
say you believe or say okay God the
Father God the son and God the Holy
Spirit and you've never placed to the
Holy Spirit how can they be equal the
holy spirit is us no the holy spirit is
God yeah but you never pray to the Holy
Spirit there certain things God will
know in our lives that we don't know we
need but God knows and the Holy Spirit
within us when we praying and you're
truly unlocked the Holy Spirit holy
spirit is one who leads in your pray is
able to that communication okay the
father is greater than the the son
because Jesus said that why do you not
pray to the father
alone and when you pray I think Jes also
there's power in the name I think
there's a verse in the Bible which says
there a there's power probably probably
Jesus why not the Holy Spirit no but I'm
saying if if you're saying that's like
you saying do you know Jesus is not God
you know you do you know why you don't
do that because the holy spirit this
Trinity thing was made up in the of NAIA
2 300 years later the Holy Spirit was
not even in the picture when you look at
early church fathers they did not even
they didn't even add the Holy Spirit
into the Trinity you need to look into
this stuff and one thing I'll leave you
guys
on is the Bible the word of God you have
to research that cuz you believe in the
resurrection Jesus dying for your sins
and Jesus being God because of the Bible
if the Bible is corrupted every single
thing of that is in life you have to
look into it but thank you you guys are
cold I don't want to hold you guys thank
you s thank you for
and thank you for the passion I enjoy
the passion you guys you guys give me
energy energy
now even even though I won't be
preaching the same thing but you gave me
the energy thank you very much sisters
it was a pleasure thank you thank you
sisters having a nice day yes yes it's
there the station is there thank
you nice I like I mean I'm not going to
lie I like the Africans passion the
energy and that's why when they come to
Islam they are so Adam aldah they have
the energy it's alhamdulillah may Allah
subh guide them and